ah better protect your bubble calm proud
sponsors of swype on Sky News yachting
swipe on the show this week using old
text to make new music we meet the
chiptune DJ's bringing back a bit you've
heard of smart phones and smart watches
how about smart pedals and the summer
sandbox epic tells The Witcher 3 live up
to the height find out in our games
ribbon hello and welcome to swipe this
week we've immerse ourselves in the
world of retro of video games but we're
not here to get reacquainted with sonic
and mario instead we're making music
because stews been taking a look at the
global phenomena known as chiptunes you
join together separate phrases so then
when you press play on those it kind of
links them all together into a single
phrase of a song
you've probably heard chiptunes at some
point even if you're not familiar with
the term also known as chip music or
8-bit music these are songs made using
retro games consoles Game Boys master
systems Ataris and Commodores make up
the orchestra in this genre and djs like
Joe of the performers this is what my
favorite ones I like playing live with I
don't know about the reason just then
them for this year holiday I've built in
some flashing LEDs on the back of it so
it is switched on and you've got like
the different multicolored flashing LEDs
in that doesn't have anything for the
music and but it is a lot of fun you may
already be dismissing chiptunes as niche
but this is a movement with thousands of
admirers around the world the superbike
festival in Manchester is an event
dedicated to 8-bit music it's been
running since 2012 and is the largest
event of its kind in the UK 400 people
went last year it's surprising what you
can get out of something that was
designed for playing games from you know
1988-89 and you put it through a big
sound system where you've got loads of
bass and all this range and suddenly
people are realizing wow you can create
these pallets of sound that cause a
whole room to rumble in an entire dance
floor of people to get up and boogie
part of the appeal of this kind of music
is the DIY element a lot of chiptune
DJ's maker at least modify their own
equipment so if you do have games
consoles like one of these lying around
at home how difficult is it to convert
it into a musical instrument modifying
the equipment and stuff is as key to me
is actually producing the music I enjoy
modifying the things and come into a
hurdle in working out the challenges to
overcome that hurdle while chiptunes are
often created in bedrooms and home
studios the DJ's insist it's the
performance element that really makes
this music come to life whether you like
the genre will depend on your taste but
if you're at the right age to remember
Super Mario and Tetris this could be
something to explore Stewart Duggan Sky
News so we've seen the kind of music you
can make from the retro consoles we've
all heard of Game Boy and snares but
what about an Atari or two Ataris with
me now is Gareth Morris AKA Gwen you're
a chiptunes DJ and these are yours yeah
that's right there are 28 re s T's there
about 30 years old they look good for 30
years old yeah they are they still do
the business old tech though got these
floppy disk about a million times
smaller than a hard disk in your normal
computer how do they work how do you use
them each disk has 26 tracks corresponds
to the 26 letters of the alphabet so the
letter keys crisp on to the songs and
then the arrow keys allow me to adjust
the tempo so I can beat mix a bit like a
DJ and a club okay and any do play clubs
don't you yeah that's right I've got
quite a few gigs coming up I'm playing
in Hamburg this weekend usually play out
every few weekends and are there any
particular tracks that the crowd really
goes well for well they love my tetris
remix actually I used to love playing
Tetris can we can we hear that out yeah
sure I know you take it away
you're watching swype still to come we
meet a time-traveling rabbit from the
future the retro fun continues in our
games review but first here's a roundup
of some of this week's other tech news
internet-connected pedals that let you
know if someone tries to steal your bike
launched on crowdfunding site IndieGoGo
this week the French startup behind the
technology says the smart pedals have a
movement detection system integrated GPS
and track your activity they also
generate their own energy so no need to
charge any batteries or carry your phone
on the move us telecoms firm verizon has
bought AOL in a 2.8 billion pound deal
it's part of verizon's push into the
mobile video market new york-based AOL
which owns the likes of the huffington
post and TechCrunch is the largest
wireless carrier in the US as well as an
internet and TV provider and it's
official minecraft is the most watched
game of all time on YouTube the building
block title reportedly has over 42
million videos on the site minecraft is
now also the second most searched for
term on YouTube other games on the site
top 10 most popular list include Grand
Theft Auto and League of Legends in
second and third place now let's get
back to the games and in this week's
games review we've got one title which
lets you live out your own game of
thrones esque fantasy adventure just
don't let it take over your whole life
here's guy Oh shitty is plagued by climb
we need a leader to tackle the issues
and the leader that's an act of a
morphic rabbit not a hero is the latest
in a long line of indie games that have
this kind of 8-bit visual aesthetic it's
kind of a really interesting kind of
British take on a genre you play one of
nine characters who were recruited by
this purple bunny called bunny Lord but
he's basically trying to become the
British prime minister and he needs to
stop something from happening in the
future so he recruits these hyper
violent gun mercenaries so looks amazing
really really cool and if you're into
those retro games then you'll definitely
get a violent today for a better
tomorrow we meet again which
your Imperial Majesty The Witcher 3 is
one of those games that comes along
every couple of years which one I was
like massive open world games like
Skyrim that people who intervene games
get drawn into and their partners
begrudgingly complain about down the pub
because they've lost their lives to them
so the witcher 3 is is obviously the
third game in the series but it's
actually the most accessible game that I
played in the sewers previous games have
been you know quite quite RPG heavy and
this one reminded me a lot of a game
called red dead redemption just because
you spend so much time on the back of a
horse and the fact that it's a very kind
of personal tale you essentially trying
to find find a girl through this massive
world and that's the main plot line
through it but there's like many
open-world action games there's so much
other stuff that you can do in this
world it's really for me the first game
since Skyrim which was a absolutely
massive immersive game to really capture
that that feeling of as if you're
playing almost in your own episode of
Game of Thrones it's got that kind of
depth to it but it's one of those games
that just draws you in and does not let
go and if you're into video games at all
it's a must
the racing genre is very very
competitive you've got forza horizon and
forza on the xbox and grants reesman on
playstation and project cars is
attempting to kind of muscle into that
genre the main developments been done
out of london and what they've attempted
to do is make a game that's got
everything so it's got all of the main
tracks that you'd expect absolutely shed
loads of cars and if you want to start
your racing career from the very bottom
like Lewis Hamilton bit flip through
karting and then go through the touring
cars and then end up through it through
the sort of racing ranks then it's got
all of that depth I'm more of a fan of
the arcade racing games like need for
speed and burnout but if you're a fan of
racing sims like Forza and like Gran
Turismo then project cars is a really
high quality entry into this particular
genre
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can stay up to date with all the
latest tech news on Sky News iPad or
smartphone apps guyanese calm and our
YouTube playlist we'll see you again
next time bye-bye
you
hmm ah better protect your bubble calm
proud sponsors of swype on Sky News